[Aplausos]
quando eu era criança eu escutava você
tem que ir pra escola e na escola eu
escutava você tem que fazer fila você
tem que tirar boas notas
você tem que usar um uniforme e mais um
monte de você tem que tudo bem
foi seguindo chegou à adolescência e com
a adolescência surge um problema
operacional na escola um conflito
você tem que fazer contra o que eu quero
fazer
eu queria fazer as minhas coisas é muito
simples eu queria andar de patins tocar
violão conversar com os meus amigos
acampar viajar conhecer lugares pessoas
ea escola também fazia parte a escola só
que não foi tão simples assim
desse conflito rebeldia dessa rebeldia
três discussões e nas três funções notas
muito boas
logotipo desafios cognitivos na minha
fase escolar eram outros problemas
concluiu o ensino médio em uma escola da
minha classe social a classe social
média só falava e fala por aí eu sei que
eu sou pobre bom e aí eu estou dando uma
escola pobres no bairro o que eu
escutava lá era você tem que se preparar
para o mercado de trabalho que se
qualificar uma reflexão que com aquele
conteúdo eles queriam que eu me
preparasse um mercado de trabalho mas
tudo bem né mercado de trabalho mercado
de trabalho e alguns momentos nós
naquela escola e os outros amigos
escutávamos tem que estudar fazer uma
faculdade
depois disso que eu concluir o ensino
médio eu decidi fazer
o que eu queria fazer nem o que você tem
que fazer isso ou aquilo falei quero
fazer as minhas coisas e o que eu queria
era viver da música
então eu fui viver um tempo me dedicando
exclusivamente para a música
isso foi muito importante primeiro pela
capacidade que a arte me deu de criar e
não de reproduzir e depois pra ver que
eu era capaz de fazer o que eu queria
fazer eu conseguir bancar minha própria
história
então depois dessa experiência estava
muito feliz é a arte me proporcionava os
sentimentos e momentos indescritíveis
só que eu queria mais quando eu percebi
que eu podia realmente fazer o que eu
queria fazer
eu fui em busca disso e com 30 anos em
2011 eu percebi que o que eu mais queria
fazer era o curso de pedagogia
eu queria fazer da escola um lugar
diferente do que foi pra mim eu queria
tornar a experiência das pessoas na
escola diferente do que foi a minha eu
queria tornar o aprendizado da escola
significativo na vida das pessoas
simples o que eu aprendi aqui que isso
tem a ver com a minha vida a thá era só
isso
então em 2012
eu entrei número uma universidade
federal na faculdade de educação o curso
de pedagogia
pronto só que não só que não mesmo
porque os moldes que a faculdade e
ofereciam foi muito chocante foi como
fazer um retrocesso voltar na escola da
minha infância e na escola da minha
adolescência
isso foi muito difícil eu não questiono
aqui o conhecimento o estudo mas como
ele se dá logo no início da faculdade eu
percebi que tudo que a faculdade
tínhamos para oferecer com as melhores
intenções possíveis
não eram suficientes para nutrir a minha
sede ea minha fome de ação e de
transformação porque foram esses motivos
que me fizeram chegar lá a ação
transformando chegou lá na faculdade
você tem que dar conta das demandas da
faculdade você tem que dar conta das
demandas da sociedade e falei ocupar
esse negócio tá ficando estranha
você tem que fazer após fazer o mestrado
fazer o doutorado fazer um pós doutorado
e falei bom essa enrascada
mas o que eu fui fazer buscar
paralelamente à faculdade o que me
completava eu queria ampliar o meu
repertório de atuação quanto o futuro
professor então comecei a fazer cursos
oficinas workshops palestras internet e
comecei a buscar nessa caminhada eu
conheci o programa guerreiros sem armas
e os guerreiros sem armas é um programa
que transforma pessoas em
transformadores de realidade da sua e
consequentemente do mundo de lá eu trago
a experiência de acreditar
acreditar em mim acreditar no outro e
acreditar na capacidade que eu tinha
para realizar os meus sonhos para o
mundo pra minha vida em um caso bem
específico com educação eu pude perceber
que eu era capaz de forma prática e
fazer da educação um instrumento de
libertação na vida das pessoas que pra
mim
humildemente ainda na universidade
acredito que educação é para nos
libertar e não para nos aprisionar
e aí fazendo tudo isso pensando em como
eu poderia trazer todos esses
ensinamentos para a educação comecei a
fazer fazer fazer fazer fazer coisas que
você faz eu transformo realidades pronto
hoje eu sigo fazendo mas fazer parte
dessa comunidade de guerreiros me fez
questionar o entendimento de mundo e de
educação
eu me pergunto até que dia nós vamos
filosofa pensar falar sobre educação nos
encontros nos debates em sala de aulas e
afins ao invés de fazer com educação
também as mudanças que se fazem cada vez
mais necessárias e urgentes na nossa
sociedade e por essas mudanças
acontecerem por meio da educação eu
preciso da faculdade num modelo que ela
é hoje precisa pra quê pra quem porquê e
quais os desafios que a faculdade me
traz frente aos desafios que eu vou
encontrar no dia a dia das escolas
essa faculdade esse modelo de escola que
a gente tem hoje
ela prepara pessoas profissionais pra
quê pra quem e por quê pra eu poder
realizar os meus sonhos que eu tenho
para a educação e variações de vários
pequenos que vai conversar comigo eu
preciso desse modelo de ensino
é ele que precisa para o mundo que eu
quero viver a vida que eu quero viver
que mundo é esse
que vida é essa eu sei que eu cheguei
aqui com muitas e muitas perguntas e
poucas respostas
talvez eu tenho uma dica vá encontrar
respostas
a minha foi questionar o que era imposto
pra mim naturalmente quando alguém fala
comigo você tem que fazer eu pergunto
você pensou em falar isso ou você está
repetindo algo que você escutou
então hoje eu sigo fazendo
já pensei muito sobre o que eu tenho que
fazer
hoje eu penso e reflito sobre o que eu
quero fazer o que você tem que fazer o
melhor
o que você quer fazer
obrigado
[Aplausos]